gang real quick before we get this
episode started summer is going into
full swing and so is the
are you garbage keep it moving 20 21
tour oh yeah we're gonna be coming to a
town near you
for a little bit of stand up and we're
gonna be answering your
garbage questions kippy tell them what
they need to know
yeah guys on uh june 22nd we'll be in
chicago still a few tickets left for
that
uh june 23rd we'll be in indy helium get
tickets for that and then buddy we're
all over the place
july 14th columbus funny bone july 15th
cleveland hilarities
august 11th rhode island comedy
connection august 12th
left boston those tickets are cooking
that's going to sell out
get those tickets then august 25th we're
at new brunswick stress factory and then
august 26th we're at magooby's joke
house in timonium
maryland right outside of baltimore i
like it gang get some ticks
come out and see it's going to be a
fantastic fun time a mix of stand-up
comedy in the ayg game
come out and hang with uncle hank and
your aunt kippy
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r.u garbage sure is a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they're growth
to be classy
or they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stroller i'm coming at you
while you're doing the intro that's
unbelievable the way you play
that whole thing i think we find out if
you're in
he gets a couple words he starts
wheezing no that sounded smooth and
clean
okay we're coming at you from down here
in aunt toddy's basement didn't even
miss a beat
[Laughter]
i saw a gentleman leaving this morning
early yeah around seven
and i saw another one leaving an hour
later yeah this is when she makes
what's a hot girl summer for her i don't
know what she's up to up there but the
white claws are working
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of are you
garbage he's the head bozo around here
so show him a little respect give it up
for kevin james ryan everybody hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are
true the roof true to roof they're
cooking baby patreon.com those numbers
are [ __ ]
elon musk put a rocket ship those things
are [ __ ] cooking and it's reusable
yeah closing in on uh yeah we're doing
doing quite well just past 1500 patrons
yeah let's go
let's go let's go uh and then live shows
coming up get tickets to the [ __ ]
live shows you bozos
couple of ticks left for ac a couple of
ticks left for indy a lot of ticks left
for indy if you're in the
india if you're in the indianapolis area
back a little bit yeah i got a couple
shows and there's way too many tickets
i got a startling number you're just
like does anyone in the city know i
exist period yeah somebody hijack
somebody hijack a school bus and take it
over to the comedy club will you they're
gonna have to sell 40 tickets a day to
sell this thing out at this point
it's [ __ ] a month away how about a
nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he makes us
all look good give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes how are
you brother had a nice steak last night
dude get out cajun ribeye about the size
of a honda dude that thing was
outrageous this is big
okay some of that patreon honey we went
to smith and walinski cajun ribeye and a
pink floyd t-shirt yeah
[ __ ] dirt bag we'll talk about it
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest
back with us here today it's a family
episode we've got a little company in
the house podcast royalty
podcast royalty not the usual bozos
you see drifting out of this hallway
yeah this is a fine upstanding gentleman
it's got a couple of bucks on them too i
want to hear all about it
just got back from [ __ ] the winter in
miami how old are you
37 37. wintering in miami
bro the place you were saying was nice
as [ __ ] too if my whole family saved up
they couldn't send one of us
to miami for the [ __ ] way that's
cause they gotta feed you
[Laughter]
i'll be taking heat on this one he's got
your [ __ ]
i don't like this he was clipping you
before you even started
i know why i love foley the most
somebody cut the tape
i'll tell you i think it's tough love
gang this gentleman is going to be
avoiding eye contact with me uh this
september at the moon tower comedy
festival
that's right i'm your accountability
partner bro
give it up for mr arkansas ladies and
gentlemen brother yeah
my man thanks for coming back hey thank
you man i'm gonna be honest
i'm trying to finagle my way on your
live show in austin i'm trying to sneak
on something oh yeah we could do that
pull out a contract right now check this
on paper
trying to sneak in there get a little
guest set you know what i mean a little
five minutes of garbage time i like it
i like it i want to know all right
success pods well documented you guys
are [ __ ] killing it you're
unbelievable
the move to miami i loved yeah i wasn't
at first but i
loved it i didn't want to come back dude
you guys went you all
listen i'm i'm a poor kid from the wrong
side of the tracks we know this
you guys moved your entire shop
from brooklyn to [ __ ] miami you set a
whole studio up
he's all got places yeah shochi's got
the pool
boxing training you're all hanging out
you're going to nice dinners oh yeah i
mean
he's going to nice dinner you guys were
all there you're all there you're
sharing desserts and stuff like that
yeah real [ __ ] classy the family dog
it's a family thing
really nice man you guys are up on a
high rise that was your place you had
the high rise i had the higher you had
like that was your place
dude that's sick i stayed further out
everybody else wanted to stay in miami
and i was like no i just want a nice
place
i lived in such a [ __ ] hole in orlando
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm outside of
disney a couple of clicks
two miles down from clearwater what the
[ __ ]
orlando's crazy it's tampa it's tampa
only orlando's too expensive what are
you doing
uh but yeah i lived in such a [ __ ]
my first like five or six years of
comedy i lived in
an apartment that you guys would have
all been like this is [ __ ] crazy
it smelled like cat pistol where were
you i was off the uh montrose stop on
like actually not far from the studio
okay was a tough look
yeah it's not dangerous but it was just
like owned by these clear
probably illegal immigrant asian people
that instead of like wall paint
they had bathroom tile all over the
kitchen
the whole
and it was a one bedroom that they
turned into a three bedroom railroad so
there's no living room
it's just kitchen my room middle room
third room and then the middle room
the guy had to walk through my room was
an alcoholic compulsive liar never had
his rent with just stuff you lived with
foley
and he was real handsy too only is
charming this guy had zero charm about
give me that fully
imagine uncharming fully yeah i am a
dirtbag but i am pretty charming
i mean look at you so likable i leave a
smile on your face on the way out the
door for a while
well that's the charm has worn out on me
i've had a decade of it
he's got three sayings that he does he
tries to get you to laugh they got your
nose i get him everyone your chemistry
with foley is a gift and a curse
it is i yeah he's my comedy wife yeah
jesus she's a big fat [ __ ]
well that's going to cost you a weekend
with the girls
[Laughter]
we're doing that now that we got a
couple of bucks yeah i go i've suffered
for so long oh
baby that i'm spending the money so i
made it a point because i almost went
broke in 2018
i remember we've had this conversation
right i was on my last
like it was money i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm gonna do i was talking to you
on a corner and you're like i i don't
know what the [ __ ]
i blacked out i don't remember talking
to you yeah i blocked that part out of
my memory yeah
awful so since then 2019 we lived in
secaucus new jersey 2020 secaucus new
jersey
not a bad place but it's [ __ ] so
caucus yeah it's cheap and then we
started making money and i was just like
let me save at least one year where it's
like
if if i get no work for a year this is a
schultz thing
i'm comfortable yeah i can live
comfortably so we got that
we're not doing that by the way we're
still month-to-month over here
hey buddy do it and it'll be worth it
just because then when you splurge it's
like bro i'm so cute it doesn't matter
i'm splurging
so we're still in the honeymoon phase of
it though and we're still shocked yeah
yeah yeah it's all very weird
it's all going to be strange like when
you and i'm not even trying to be fake
humble when you guys say like podcast
royals i'm like yeah they're talking
about andrew i'm just here
no what they did daddy here this is
there's
a we you know there's we've had this
conversation too
uh there's very few people that podcast
partners that have really good chemistry
you and andrew that you guys well i
think we we we have some of it
uh the history has had it's like this
thing it's like this the given
[Laughter]
our doors are always open on out the
hyenas with the patreon.com
flu dude oh that's what i did
i probably love it that was the start of
them yeah no that was it
no that was the nail in the coffin that
was that's i know this i saw it happen
i saw it i missed the show i missed
those two together yeah they were great
yeah
but you guys andrew have that that's why
you guys are so successful thank you but
uh i don't even remember what we're
talking about
talking about cash that's what we're
playing so the miami move uh we were
just
i was telling my girl like yo she hates
the city but i was like
i think i just lose on so many small
debates i don't even fight also your
girl
is so pretty to the point it's like how
the [ __ ] did you get her she wins every
argument
yeah yeah exactly but everyone in the
whole squad's attractive
yeah you guys you guys rolled down to
miami with like everybody was a 10. yeah
hold on a second that's what i want to
ask you even just that the the
the living the dream of of just that
like was there ever
was your girl ever not going to come was
it like hey like because i mean she's
got a life up here
she's got a life up here and
theoretically you're going for work so
you're at the point now where you can
say hey
whatever you're doing [ __ ] it we're
moving to miami
yeah but here's what's crazy on some
like universe type [ __ ] for years since
like 2017 she's always said i want to
live in miami
and we visit a couple times and she's
like no i want to live here
so when we were deciding between miami
and austin we had literally
just signed a lease or like verbally
agreed to a place and given a deposit
for a place in new york okay i was
telling her like i know you hate the
city but we need to lean into my career
right now because i think good things
could happen if we [ __ ] lean in
deuce as many spots as possible et
cetera et cetera so she's like fine we
agreed to a place in new york nice place
nothing crazy crazy nice
and then the night we after we verbally
agree and send the deposit
schultz is like yo i think we need to go
we need to leave new york it sucks right
now
and i'm freaking out like what the [ __ ]
is going on we just [ __ ] put money
into this place what's going on
and then uh when we talked about new
york or miami or austin my girl was like
yo if it's miami
you don't even have to ask me i'm there
if it's austin i'll enjoy the new place
you guys enjoy austin
sure and i want to know okay she would
have stayed yeah i wanted austin because
my parents are right there and they're
not
right here but we missed that [ __ ]
epic ice storm not being there
yeah yeah yeah but yeah as soon as we
went to miami she was in she was like
let's go
my family's here and all my friends are
here but like i want to experience this
and she loved it she was she working
does she have she
worked remote thanks to colvin she was
working remote so it didn't matter so
now you're working remote looking at
a beach damn you know what happens
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] the team is
killing it because we're all down there
together you're like i said you were
going out you having cocktail parties
you're doing it yeah it was a good life
man it was a breakfast
even if you're working it feels like a
vacation yeah miami's got a great
like way of that i feel like i'm on
vacation all the time new york if you're
on vacation you feel like you're working
i'm going to the store it feels
exhausting
i don't know i started wearing shorts
exclusively so i feel like i'm on
vacation
buddy the train with jeans i forgot
about that [ __ ] nightmare
that's a job in and of itself the subway
with jeans just
chafing and rashes
i did not want to come back doug i bet
andrew i think for his so much his
comedy is fighting back against a
society around him
so much of my comedy is fighting back
against the girlfriend around me
that's there wherever i go for him it's
like no i need the kind of new york um
angst and anger that i can kind of fight
against miami everybody it's a vacation
city everybody
relax everybody's chilling everybody's
got a couple of cocktails in him yeah so
i think that was a major impetus for him
being like yo if i want to be the goat
santa we can't
i can't be here and i want to be the
ghost stand up as well but my
inspiration like it tends to be at home
for now
so but when he was like we need to go
back i think that's why and so i'm not
fighting it and plus what leverage do i
have
but i'm not fighting it
i tell everybody life is a leverage game
and if you don't think i understand that
in my own life you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
i was thinking milwaukee to be honest
with you what do you think andrew got
more relationship in my
my engagement than i do like if you got
more leverage
he got the left hey when we getting
married drew you tell me
[Laughter]
we got to check the dates on chelsea
that robin can't tell batman not to sell
wayne manor
yeah i'm saying right exactly exactly so
what'd you do with the apartment that
you put the deposit down did you just
forget about the deposit [ __ ] it off
i had to eat it yeah but i mean
everybody else is cheating i've seen
deposits over here i know
yeah yeah but what am i going to do am i
going to eat the podcast
i can't pull again
get a little bit of that steak sauce
from last night i can eat about anything
no but that's good to have that
flexibility to be able to do that [ __ ]
it i'm going on miami
yeah so we moved all of our [ __ ] out of
our our lease is already up in our old
place we moved all of our [ __ ] out one
weekend
she her mom was coming in from india she
lives back and forth so
okay i had to fly back and forth for a
few weeks and then we moved out one
weekend
and then put it all in storage and then
just moved back like a week ago where
are you at in the city
uh on like like west end area oh
west end is class you guys got a new
place now you're all settled in any
place
so from your [ __ ] high rise in miami
to a new place yeah yeah yeah yeah well
i couldn't take her back to secaucus
yeah yeah you can't go you can't go
miami
yeah you guys familiar with the j train
what the [ __ ] you want to go to forest
hills
i hear jackson heights and what'd you
get one bedroom two bedroom
two you got to do it got a little office
and then you know family visits they
have a place to stay et cetera all that
but like i got my desk
that i'm getting all the furniture and
i'm gonna have my space and then we're
gonna try to make that work
[ __ ] clean living i love it ready
we're trying yo no more garbage time
yeah we're trying we're yeah we're
trying i just took him on his first limo
ride by the way oh i saw that that's
fine i thought there'd be more people on
it
he was like do we have to stop and pick
up more people i'm like dude was it hard
for you to not do cocaine
i look over he's got a mirror he pulled
it off the wall
he was literally like are there mics and
cameras back here are they checking out
can we do weird stuff yeah he's like are
they spying on us i'm like
it's i got it off a russian guy in
midtown doesn't it make sense to you
that a
the limousine company would have a
camera in there in case kids are doing
something bad in the back do you think
rich people haven't evolved since 1998
do you think they're taking limos now
yeah rich people aren't nobody taking
helicopters
that's what i'm saying don't you think
they'd be watching you because i
wouldn't want to be doing rippers back
there
and have igor in the front keeping an
eye on me yeah it was
yeah you're the target yeah that's what
i'm saying they're trying to bring down
you're going after they're trying to
bring you dude yeah
i was like it's not ab scam your guy
doesn't even speak [ __ ] english
he was a little chatty by the way yeah
oh man
anyway buddy thank you for coming and
sitting with us thank you for being here
thank you for for for going over
that with me because i love it [ __ ]
thank you i'm fascinated by the
uh the whole winner we live in
vicariously for you guys i know we were
when we go out i
i feel like i feel like you and schultzy
a little bit we were sharing a couple of
things you got it y'all are on your way
this is a [ __ ] great
stone crabs that steakhouse with the
chimichurri sauce whatever you had
it's dim lighting dude he could see an
instagram story
from [ __ ] three years ago and
remember what the sides were
i'm not even [ __ ] around with you not
even no they ain't there a couple of
times
it was tuesday the 9th they went back on
the 22nd
pierre was their waiter yeah if dude if
it has to do with food it is
[ __ ] programmed into his head it's
listen it's not that it's just the
elegance of it it's it's the
the doing things right working hard with
your with your with your best friends
making great stuff
and then doing and then doing things
nice that's all it is it had nothing to
do with the truffle lobster mac and
cheese
and i resent any comments saying
otherwise no that's the idea but it does
get tricky and one thing i've always
said
that i'm like very big on is the
friendship has to come before the
podcast even if this is
all of my income the friendship has to
come first if it costs me my friendship
i have to say i'm walking
and i'm not saying it's going to be
super easy to do because as
numbers rise and as money rises stakes
arise sure
you start looking at the stakes
differently even everybody's got those
kind of stakes
yeah you're talking about porterhouse
yeah you are though that's like not
going to be
a crazy thing to use go to a fancy
steakhouse and and live it up like it's
like all right cool i can do that now
but the emotional investment that comes
with that gets higher because it's like
oh [ __ ] now we have a lot more to lose
yeah even though you started with
nothing you're like i can't go back
there
so for me i've set a thing in my mind
that is the friendship has to come first
and i know andrew has done that too he's
always been super loyal to me
so that's one thing we have that gives
me hope that we can do this for a long
time
because a lot of this [ __ ] falls apart
when it gets too successful and then
everything gets too
you're so invested in this the
insecurities and paranoia start playing
in and so like
if andrew like we see another podcast
where it's like oh this guy wants to do
this thing and the other person feels
away like andrew got a netflix special
bet you do that that's only going to
help our numbers yeah you want to make
it andrew
all boats rising because you explained
to me more people will find it and this
is the fact that when you search andrew
schultz before on itunes
our podcast wouldn't come up because it
was called flagrant 2. andrew schultz's
flagrant tool you search andrew schultz
and you're a fan of his that [ __ ] pops
up and our numbers went up
so every time i've swallowed my ego
we've won that's great
so and as as i as my profile raises
there will be times where he'll have to
swallow his ego god willing you know i
mean like that's the idea
and the friendship starts to come first
and it's it's just gonna be a thing that
you guys are gonna deal with i'm telling
you because you're on that road
and it's not like a bad oh [ __ ] you guys
i'm saying you're because you're good
this is going to become a thing thank
you the friendship has to come first
yeah because yeah without the camera i'm
thinking kevin ryan presents are you
garbage
i'm an seo guy
i was gonna say i need to borrow a
couple of dollars off yeah no
uh we also our and the fans we we do it
behind
uh on the patreon we really kind of
[ __ ] it's you know uh because there's
no one there it's just me and him kind
of venting and [ __ ]
um they're there too yeah they're like
but even you you're
already starting you're like we're very
mean to each other
we have a very dysfunctional
relationship we have for a decade yeah
like we yell
and scream at each other and it's like
that just comes from the [ __ ] up
families we came from
so love you mom are you talking to your
dad yet no who
we're having a good time you're right
sucker
kevin starts crying oh man
we were just sitting here so won't you
eat my hair
so screaming
this guy is in it right now i don't even
think about that guy
oh man
oh that's good well i mean paladin
no you guys have a very mean like um
yeah we
air it out but he said it friendship
first can't go anywhere
you heard it your first song do you
think this show's ever gonna stop i'm
like well the beatles broke up dude
yeah i think the garbage podcast might
come to an end at some point yeah
never gang let's talk about our good
friends at hello
fresh kippy how do you feel about them
over there love those guys and gals run
a top-notch operation i gotta tell you
it's clean living over there at
hellofresh with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your get the trips to
the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy
fun and affordable and that's why why
it's america's number one meal
numero uno gang hit you with a couple of
special things about hello fresh let me
tell you this
what do you got they cut meal plan they
cut you know planning and
time with the grocery store a lot of
stuff they get rid of it all and they
also have meals
that you can make within 15 20 minutes
have them on a table for your family
bing boom bat no stress oh baby ah they
sent us
big boxes of stuff big box big boxes
of food i think you got the the locale
option right i got the locale i got some
grilled cajun shrimp
kale with uh with caesar salad or with
kale scale salad
top shelf yeah we got uh we got a pork
dish this was phenomenal i'm not even
that big of a poor guy this was a home
run we got the pork dish too it was
crazy the sauce the
the brown sauce was like sweet and tangy
it was unbelievable
it was top-notch guys check it out they
got a ton of recipes whatever you're
into they
got if it's locale uh you know meat no
meat whatever you want they got it
go to hellofresh.com garbage12
slash garbage 12 use promo code
garbage12 for 12
free meals including that's why they're
doing the 12.
including free shipping buddy 12 free
meals
including the shipping i'm going to say
it one more time write it down
get it tattooed on you whatever you need
to do go to hellofresh.com
garbage 12 use promo code garbage 12
you'll get 12 free meals
including free shipping it's a
no-brainer
do it gang let's talk about our good
friends over there at mint mobile after
years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off
by big wireless providers big bozos if
we've learned anything
there's always a catch yeah okay so when
we first heard about mint
and we heard about their 15 a month plan
we thought to ourselves oh my god what
are we doing got to be a catch
yeah they're sneaking something by us
fine print something
couldn't be further from the truth
here's the deal there is no catch
they create their savings by going
around the middleman and giving the
savings right on to you
yeah guys they sent us uh they sent us a
mint mobile plan to use it's fantastic
actually my wife has been using it for
years
she got onto it early because she was
coming over uh from europe for
times we needed to get her a plan
without getting you know the the two
three four five-year contract
sometimes you got to give up your first
born to be with someone sure companies
you know what i mean
so we got this for it and she's just
kept it it's that easy it's simple it's
the same service you get
how funny is that before we were
advertising with it for years she's been
using it
mobile i they came across that they're
like hey do you want to admit mobile go
i love it
that's destiny shout out to mobile they
send it to you it's easy peasy so if
you're looking for extra savings they
offer premium wireless for just 15 bucks
a month
um use your own phone and you get your
mint mobile plan same phone number the
whole nine yards all your contacts stay
the same and if you're not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee
switch to mint mobile get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bones a month
get it shipped right to you for free go
to mintmobile.com
garbage one more time big man that's
mintmobile.com
garbage now back to the show all right
speaking of family this is a pretty good
one uh guys so as you know when you join
the patreon uh we will answer your
garbage question on the air it's the
best way to do it
uh we just get so many submissions um
bob at a bebop we have
are you backlogged we have a backlog
let's get through it a little bit we're
working
let's clear out the inbox uh well i mean
they're they're joining their kids
all right this one's from alex it has to
do with family does your family kiss
each other on the mouth
no there's some families that do that i
have a couple of people in my family
that do that are they garbage or is that
evolved
no that's garbage i feel like it's a
little garbage wait who kisses who on
the mouth
you kiss your dad on the mouth if you
[ __ ] a [ __ ] real one kevin
that show me your move next time next
time you see him at wawa park just make
out with him
like the end of pretty woman i'm telling
you all your problems go away
if i just walked up and said hey i'm
tired of this [ __ ] you're my father and
you grab his cheeks and you're planting
one on the [ __ ] mouth
what's he gonna do get the [ __ ] off what
no
he's gonna be like man that was really
[ __ ] really cool then
like guys we must really want to move on
oh yeah he must have put the pants
behind him
who kisses on the mouth um
there's an uncle what's what i'm not to
me anymore
as a kid i thought i was guaranteed you
were going to say my mom kisses the
grandkids who are a little i'm shorter
than you i used to kiss my mom in the
mouth at like five and then i remember
being like i just got to stop
something yeah something like that an
uncle
yeah uh a great guy i had a buddy i had
a buddy who's like we would like he had
like
he was his house was like the party
house because his dad was a single dad
and he'd be like all right i'm going to
bed we'd all be like drinking or
whatever in high school he'd be like
come here and give me a kiss
you have to like walk over and kiss his
dad on the lips before he went to bed
and we were like this is when you were
boozing yeah like this
is freaking [ __ ] cheesy kissing your son
with beer breath
yeah that's a drunk move though kiss on
the lips that's it by accident
yeah wow any kiss on the lips my
sister-in-law my sister-in-law doesn't
even
she she leans in with like her head when
i go in to give her a kiss on the cheek
yeah i mean i couldn't imagine you
coming in to plant one on somebody dude
that beard those teeth no way i never do
i always just touch
cheeks i'm not kissing anybody that's
weird you guys are [ __ ] weird about
that well yeah
what's on the cheek bro
patreon.com do you kiss your family
members like your mom
mom gets a kiss on the lips i mean a
kiss on the cheeks okay yeah my mom and
dad get smooches all the time
uh my little like cousin's sister gets a
kiss on the top of her head yeah you go
top of the head with the kids yeah
she's weird she's like 29 30 but like
i'm like yeah kissing the cheek feels
weird for sister
sure kiss top of the head top of the
head it's funny if i'm tall enough to do
that i'm not always
yeah but yeah there's like a hierarchy
of it there's an appropriate way to do
it mm-hmm
for example 100 in my family you get
[ __ ] up plant one right
i give my mom and dad kiss i snuggle
with my dad and give him kisses on his
head joking around and stuff like that
i'll go with him but no
lips snuggles i'd rather kiss my dad up
than snuggling i mean like give him a
big hug and stuff like that squeeze him
i get a hug but what isn't stuff like
that like you know like yeah
get over here doing that kind of thing
the not gay way yeah
it's like when you hug a guy with your
pet twice in the back back yeah yeah
yeah yeah do not be gay
yeah you have no pants on it you still
pat on the back
you gotta like be aggressive with a guy
when you're hugging get over here you
know yeah yeah
keep you rubbing noodles as long as
there's like a word all code for i'm not
gay
what about you t-bone you smooching i
mean
he comes from a loveless family i think
that's not true feel like you come from
the most love out of all of us
yeah but it's just remote a loveless
family what is it what does remote mean
that's via the phone yeah yeah
super close yeah oh you don't see them
that much you're a chicago guy right
uh i was out there for like 11 years
yeah okay do you say i love you after
the phone call of course
t-bone or uh akash everybody reach it to
everybody yeah i say it's everybody
i mean it and as i get older i'm like yo
you don't know what could happen tell
[ __ ] you love them yeah
yeah it's true i'll never forget one
time i did give
like i was going to sleep i was like 11.
i gave my dad a kiss on the cheek
and then our neighbor was there drinking
with my dad and i went to give him a hug
and i just like instinctively kissed her
cheek and it was and it still haunts me
to this day it made the vibe
so weird and i was like why the [ __ ] did
i do that
that's tough dude hey jack what's with
the little one huh
come over to watch a ball game and have
a couple of beers
it's [ __ ] trying to make out with me
round in second base
this kid's putting the full cord press
on me doesn't he see the ring what's the
deal
oh dude this morning i had a horrible i
got they had that age-old thing i got
coffee and i was walking down the street
and i saw my friend
just the deli guys get over here pedro
uh no i saw my wife's friend who lives
in our building and like we just started
hanging out
i just started hanging out with her and
like we're on like a kind of a hugging
basis
i saw her on saturday and we hugged high
and by
yeah so i saw her this morning walking
the kid and i'm like oh hey how you
doing and i went for it and she didn't
oh
dude i was like arms out wow turned to
get the kids what uh
dude i was just standing on the corner
like this i was like okay all right just
stretch it was a tough look
buddy that's on her [ __ ] heart i know
but i'm the guy still in the corner
doing this
it's a new scandinavian yoga i'm trying
anyway check it out good class uh dork
i know ouch talk about you guys you guys
say i love you to each other
i do you have everybody on our pie says
i love you
i said i love you to every person i'm
usually the first to leave so i say i
love you to everybody on the way out
yeah they say i love you back
i usually tell him i love him on the
phone i usually don't get it
you know you guys still dealing with his
dad
he's got a lot of bottle up in here but
he comes like a three liter oh so when
we went on
how are you going to love you and not
his own father he's got to deal with
that every time he
every time he says he that's in the back
of his mind i can't say it
i liked it better when we were calling
him fat what am i doing here am i a
father figure to you
i have more money than you i'm more
successful than what are you doing you
sound
that's exactly what you want to say to
his dad right now
toby got it and i got friends
and they love me and they tell me they
love me
and some of them even kissed me on the
mouth
can you say that you on the mouth dad
other girl men who smooch you dad
oh my god oh dude i'm sweating oh that's
too funny no you are not a father figure
well very paternal of him he's gonna
have a heart attack soon
you are my dad that's bothering me yeah
all right that's old man
i am leaving you my watch in my will you
keep asking him to watch his health he
keeps not doing it
oh yeah you are i tell you to quit
smoking you're not doing that he's very
paternal in these ways you didn't get me
if
you get me a christmas present that was
just like my dad
was just like my dad you forgot my
birthday i wasn't at your wedding
you both weren't at my wedding
[ __ ] up thing is we were actually
having a drink together yeah he's like
you two just sit at the bar he's a good
kid i love him
[Laughter]
show you how to throw a curveball
make out with your mom
jesus nice i'm sweating oh [ __ ]
oh man me too all right just hold on can
i say this
sure what a great question
who asked that that was from alexander
oh all right buddy
shout out to alexander all right this
one's from jordan ever worn jeans with
sandals
no but i'm indian so i should that's
what i'm like i saved
i pulled this for you i'm garbage for
not i don't like flip-flops and i feel
like a bit of a sell-out because of that
yeah you're abandoning your roof because
i'm not like i don't know nearly enough
about india so
anything that makes me feel like i'm i
should be doing this as an indian
i get real insecure about it like if you
ask me to eat indian food
and i'm like no like what i feel i'm
like
what am i doing i should want to eat
indian food somebody asked people
restaurant no that's not that's not
indian it's not real house indian food
yeah but in my mind i'm like
how white am i jesus christ what i'm
trying to eat [ __ ] bennigan's what am
i
shout out because you wouldn't want to
eat anything all the time if you're
italian you don't always want [ __ ]
spaghetti
[Applause]
jesus christ they never shut up about
that i got some mommy now
[ __ ] parm they're never saying no to
chicken pox either yeah neither do i
though big chicken parm guy
i don't get it chicken farm do you have
that a lot do you have like your your
yeah he hates i get him i get him all
the time and he
what is it uh yeah i don't know what
what do you do what's going on
they don't like chicken i don't get it
i'm sorry the what i just don't get it
have a chicken parmesan sandwich
have a fried chicken sandwich it is with
meat with cheese and sauce
nah this is not truly fried it's just
like breaded and kind of fried
and then it's like kind of dry but not
really you're eating sauced and covered
it's a mediocre sandwich
wow hot take maybe that's why i don't
italian shorts that was not a hot cake
first of all yeah you [ __ ] italian
cucks i can't believe you gave him that
as a hot tape yeah that's
it yeah yeah
actually if i felt it in my loins i felt
it um chicken parm's fantastic sandwich
but i will say
this i do prefer the entree over the
sandwich that makes sense
no why can't why take a kind of dry food
and then put it in between two drier
foods man you're making points
but you're really frustrated because i
love chicken parsley you can't beat the
entree though because it comes with a
side of pasta yeah that pasta always
stinks though
i'm there for the meat the cheese and
the sauce i don't need the [ __ ]
noodles that we're gonna have to go
get fried chicken i do from time to time
um does your do your did you like your
dad do you have your do you have
brothers
yeah mike are they all sandals are you
older my dad is a sandals guy if you're
from india you are sandals guy and
that's just what
that's santa's a joke this is what it is
i don't and then my brother's not
because again he grew up here but if
you're from india you are sandals
through and through
your brother dressed like you like no no
pop urban
no he was more white and i was more
because there's no way to act indian
when we were growing up like indians are
kind of forming an identity now
yeah but you guys you guys are really
putting on the hard press
there's a lot of cool indians we're
trying to really rush out there yeah but
still it's like
people used to be like oh why don't you
act indian i'm like what do you want me
to do
better or worse if somebody says you're
acting black you kind of know what that
means
sure if somebody says you're acting
white you know what you know what that
means too if somebody says you're acting
indian it's just like
you've got flip-flops yeah i got
flip-flops i'm pre-med like that's it
flip-flops in a decent gpa yeah exactly
so i did my best to do that and then i
couldn't so here i am
trying to figure it out trying to not be
too black and not be too white
it's working for you buddy thanks buddy
you're a cool guy you're a cool
confident guy i could say this i would
like to be full-time flip-flops
you got bad toes though i gotta take
care of them you just saw i
i was in between petties at the time
when you saw them
but my feet are actually good they do
need a good scrubbing to get all that
dead skin off
then that doesn't sound good you can't
say i got to get all that [ __ ]
maintenance after you've made they look
good i've no it's not
but not everybody in flip-flops has good
feet how strong does your
nail tech have to be to lift your
[ __ ] ham
see when they move
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] um this one's not a this is just
a joke
this is from michael ever put ten
dollars on patreon with only twenty
dollars in your bank account that is our
fan base right there
that's a [ __ ] fan that's i love that
we get people that
they go hey listen if it hits my account
today it's going to overdraw so i'm
going to pause and then just hey who's
that michael
yeah michael let me tell you something
if i'm in your city
i you get a free ticket to my show oh
look at that yeah
not ours by the way especially in india
not not ours in indy
well i'm gonna tell you this in kansas
city they're probably gonna have to give
away free tickets anyway so
if you live there it might as well go to
you i like it
you're moving tickets though no yeah but
it's i opened for you in
philly philly was a good tournament five
sold out shows
yeah it was really fun um phoenix i
didn't sell any tickets up to the day i
was freaking out and then a bunch of
walk-ups came
which is cool i'm hoping to say the same
thing happened in kansas city because
they sent me the numbers and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] is happening
this is gonna be i'm doing shows for
chairs and i'm flying people out now
because i'm trying to
by the way he up he rolls with a crew
when he goes out and you're you're real
generous with those venmos
oh yeah yeah he was like oh here get
yourself a room for the weekend venmo me
to money right away
yeah i wanted to [ __ ] withdraw that
before you [ __ ] pulled it back
and that's another thing i mean the
hotel was closed andrew always took such
good care of me i'm like i can't
be stingy with the people around sure of
course that guy overpays me for sure
so like if you're coming i don't want
you to have to come out of pocket for
anything yeah like i'm getting a room
it's like bro
i can't have it he sent me the link he's
like here get the room and then the link
in the video at the same time
classy moves it's well documented
there's no disputing
kid's all [ __ ] class he's doing it
right he does it nice
yeah but it's uh i'm trying to make
content out of like having my features
on the road then we all come on stage at
the same time and try to do like
if we can make that extra content great
then it kind of kind of pays for itself
in that way
sure but yeah you got to sell tickets
for that to work
so i'm looking at these numbers and i'm
about to lose thousands of dollars
thousands of dollars holy [ __ ]
better idea instead of flying we rent a
van
we move the show to hoboken get plenty
of content under that
i got a great place in c caucus
uh because we do the same thing so we so
it's me and foley and we we bring out
t-bone
and then uh me and him close out the
shows together taking
questions from the audience um have you
know live questions from the audience
but we're noticing like all right i'm
like oh so it's three plane tickets yeah
and it's like we fly to columbus and
then from columbus to cleveland back to
new york so it's like
you're looking i'm like oh we're [ __ ]
two grand in plane tickets already yeah
before we even get hotels too hotels add
up meals add up
uh [ __ ] uber's at us oh yeah yeah
everything adds up you triple all your
expenses and you get paid the same
which is why we have t-shirts that are
only available on the tour at the live
shows
i'm like this guy regardless though
that's always kind of been the way that
i operate the guy
what are we talking about the 10 and the
20. yeah hey you guys just went off on a
tangent about rich guy [ __ ]
about flying people out merch and stuff
like that about losing money man
yeah yeah i've always been like that if
i have twenty bucks a day somebody we
know
yeah oh dude last night in the limo
somebody we were filming and someone
called and he's like
i think it was like the it was a
doctor's voice or something it was
it was those sirens at hawaiian airlines
hawaiian airlines
trying to bring me up on the rocks and
he's going but when are you processing
the charge
and she's going i had to make a move
real quick she's going
she's going tonight he's like but like
not like now or like
at 8 pm how many minutes from when this
phone disconnects dude he goes okay bye
he hangs up and he's in his bank
[ __ ] moving money around oh you got a
check and you got a savings you on that
kevin hart
that's right i got to zip it over zip it
back i have two
checkings oh [ __ ] both empty yeah
it's not a sign of wealth
two chickens bro i got 40 credit cards
that's exactly it oh [ __ ] tilt it out
what is your
this is a big one what's your credit
limit this isn't from again this is what
we ask a lot what's your credit limit i
don't remember
you ballpark it 30-ish thousand what
like that well your credit you're voting
on one card can i be honest with you
that was my credit 10 years ago
30 grand i don't know what it is now
holy [ __ ]
crap i can't even look at you in the eye
anymore buy an airplane
i was broke with a 30 grand credit limit
and i was about to be like this is our
money for
we got yeah guess ours yeah um
twelve to fifteen thousand yeah okay
what's wrong just remember i didn't have
the beard when i got the credit card
okay so you probably all right you were
younger
maybe no this is this is this is within
the last year things are better than the
latest both got credit cards within the
past things are better than the last
year
so i'm against toby's too toby is with
about 5000 probably
i i don't have a credit card grow up
he does he has an amex card that's a
credit card but that's the fancy of all
that but it's
linked to his brother's account or
something like that what are they
telling you that's not a credit card at
amex for you're about to get [ __ ] in
the ass on interest
be late and see if it's not a credit
card
it's technically a charge card hey bob i
told this long hair on the phone that he
needed to pay it in his back
dumb ass believe me yeah the hippie
bought it all right so i guess you would
be 5 000. you're about 15 i was if i had
to guess 12 to 15.
foley twenty dollars
uh you are the gentleman from texas is
way off
oh yeah you are way way up what do you
have five
hundred thousand no i'm
you're you're never going to look at me
mine's more than his his is more than
mine i'm the professional one
i know that's why i thought you had your
[ __ ] together i know what we talked
about buying real estate do you remember
that sure buying an entire neighborhood
you buying real estate
we talked about i didn't have money at
the time you had 30k on you
you two are spitballing no one's got a
thing to make a move all right go ahead
talk to the agent wait
you go ahead and talk to the agent wait
i thought you were buying we wanted to
buy land in detroit because that's what
we could afford back when it was like
houses for a dollar
what though you two are sitting there i
didn't want to 250 is what is credit
level
my credit limit is two hundred dollars
put the shovel away put the gold shovel
away
put the ribbon away i don't want you
getting upside down with a couple of
bulldogs
holy [ __ ] my bad oh my gosh
this is 500. my god dude
i just asked him to raise it too they
said no i can buy you
i can buy you and sell you kippy
two and a half times dude we are tanking
our pets heads are falling
what the [ __ ] yo 500 that's possible how
the [ __ ] did you have 30 grand in
credit 10 years ago you just don't be
late that's all you got to do
why people are on time with everything
no they're not my kind
when did you get your first credit card
college and
so okay no credit before that you live
at your parents
uh you go to college who gets you the
credit card your parents or you apply
yourself for a credit card
i think my dad might have applied okay
to help you build your credit
no my dad i couldn't apply for him no no
no but i mean like he was like you need
a credit card
i never had that yeah yeah okay yeah so
when did you get started
i had well then i i had a macy's credit
card when i worked at macy's and that
really jammed me up
that was a couple of years of bad bad
missed payments
and lose money at the top this guy's
backwards in bed sheets
i'm upside down in a pair of trousers
oh my god dude a couple of duvet covers
[ __ ] psyched the whole ship jesus
christ
man macy's i gotta see if we if the
corporate company can get a poke
addiction like in general
holy [ __ ] all right so you were you were
jammed up at macy's
how old were you when you cleared that
debt not college loans
macy's credit card well college loans
got me too when those things kicked in
they they they really beat me up
wait so when you don't pay those back
they ruin that ruins your credit too
everything really knowledgeable
that's massive my parents were going
broke when i was graduating college but
they were like we're going to pay off
your college yeah that's like a
probably an immigrant thing in general
but specifically with indians education
is so important
they paid off most of it i paid off at
the end because i was like y'all clearly
can't do this right now
um and i had a little i had a job and i
was just saving like i didn't spend [ __ ]
i didn't holler at girls i didn't drink
so i was like i'll take care of the rest
it wasn't much but um
that helped a lot so to your credit and
to
ding my own [ __ ] like i didn't have to
do that massive college loan yeah yeah
yeah
uh 500 is embarrassing though it's
200.50
i know and i ask them to raise it they
won't budge they won't move
i think they know we know each other do
you know what your credit score is
offhand
730 something damn not bad not bad but
that's gotta be that to get to 30k
well i i had a great credit score but
then i had a couple hospital bills that
when i was going broke i was like
i after insurance they were charging me
four thousand and i was like i'm not
doing that on principal [ __ ] you
and then it dig my score way less than
you think so worth it to say four
thousand dollars
so worth it like so worth it guys i i
can't explain to you how much you don't
really
like it i've also heard if you pay back
like a dollar a month they won't put it
on your credit
for hospitals that might be true i don't
know
just pay them the [ __ ] barest minimum
you can pay
and it won't ding your credit but i was
so goddamn lazy and i was like yeah
whatever fun
and then i my credit score my credit
score would be touching 800 i think it
wasn't for that
i think i think pretty good not
too shabby i was 5 35 for a while do you
have an american express card
i do you do what color is it
not black it's up there it's platinum
that's great you know what's cool though
this is actually a little triumph he
looked at me like it was purple
yeah no i i yeah
i couldn't get your message for a while
because yeah well
my parents had a uh we had a bunch of
gnc's when i was a kid like the vitamin
stores ironically i was very fat at the
time but
we lost all of them and then we were
like they didn't want to work for
somebody else my dad wouldn't open a
restaurant his whole
credit was [ __ ] so i was like look
open a corporation i'll be the head of
the corporation
fine uh don't worry about it how old are
you at this i was in college
so they open a restaurant in my name
it's a corporation in my name so it's
not gonna [ __ ] my credit completely
it hurts it a bit but also there was an
amex that my dad was like look i can't
afford to pay this back it's in your
name
and it was like 30k or whatever and then
we just never paid it back
i forgot about it like six years later i
tried to get a delta skymiles card that
partnered with them oh they got me two
[ __ ] i forgot about them i [ __ ] you
delta
yeah 29 or some [ __ ] yeah buddy do you
not know how credit cards
work i know how they work i just don't
have the money to pay them
then don't spend the [ __ ] card i
don't anymore and they figured capital
one figured that out too only give them
200 bucks because that's all he pays us
okay good it'll build up but here's the
thing after so i tried to get a card
like six seven years later and i was
like bro how are you rejecting me for
this [ __ ] card
and they're like well you actually owe
us um you know like thirty thousand
dollars from this card or whatever
and all my indeed indignation went so
polite i was like
alright well you know hey you guys gotta
do what you gotta
you do at the end of the day you're
trying to run a business here i get that
hey writer's right thanks for your time
we'll talk to you later bye but then i
applied again at the end of this year
the beginning of this year and i was i
got it and i was like oh [ __ ] i made it
like not only can i get an mx now i got
the mx platinum
uh i say i have to say hopefully that's
you know hopeful for you guys but also
most of this [ __ ] lasts 10 years
what about the 30 yeah 10 years a lot of
mine's gonna be clear soon
a lot of it's seven seven eight years
and a lot of mine's gonna be [ __ ]
forgotten about yeah i thought it was
ten but you might be seven eight
wait so the thirty doesn't go on bruh
it's gone i don't know i'm nothing no
more
damn hurt my credit a little bit no i'm
good how's the restaurant doing
oh it's gone what kind of was it indian
food
no it was like healthier fast food i
don't know why we didn't just do indian
food matter of fact like what the [ __ ]
are we thinking yeah
i don't know we were thinking trying to
do that and it was also like we had your
own restaurant we had to start like a
little we don't do like a franchise it
was like an established name but not
really because we couldn't get an
established name so we want one that we
thought was up and coming yeah
a lot of good lessons in going broke
both times i've been going broke in my
life it's been very sobering
it takes away the 30 dollar credit limit
away a little bit though
yeah oh yeah for sure we find that
you're you're who you are yeah yeah
you're in the hold of capital one yeah
well i technically yeah
yeah they gave me 30. i owe them 32
though that's why they gave me that
one last question what's what's your
mile situation right now
solid solid i think hundreds of
thousands yeah
really yeah damn yeah you're buying the
tickets for the team too
take us for the team and then you get
the right miles hard you get [ __ ]
three points for double
you spend on dining or whatever listen i
i know i cashed out one of my cards
but uh i think the other one's at like
600. i love this adult stuff i got 9
000 hawaiian airlines miles i feel like
a king
i don't know where i'm going to go maybe
around the world buddy i love miles dude
i'm such a [ __ ] dweeb for miles
i love that i don't know what it is but
i
just want to get into that miles lounge
cool right
it's not as nice as you think you get
the [ __ ]
club access and really you just get a
charger that's all you get yeah i've
been in the one
for when i have the delta card yeah
there's some snacks
club or whatever yeah but the snacks are
trash the emerald club i've heard is the
nicest but the united club united sucks
in general the reason i stay with them
is because so few people like to fly
them i have a better chance of getting
upgraded
delta everybody's flying so you don't
know who's going to get upgraded
for a cold soda and a couple of goldfish
oh yeah no
no you need that for sure and a seat
belt extender i got two already
he steals them if you ever want a plane
if you're on an odd plane get me one
i collected a seatbelt extender from an
airbus and from a boeing why
so i don't have to ask when i get on the
plane like a fatty because they [ __ ]
broadcast it
okay there's no secrecy when hunters put
a buck's head up on the wall
[Laughter]
this was to cleveland this one was fat
conquest
thank you buddy my bad oh yeah [ __ ] i
don't even see it that was on me some
[ __ ] what did you say around on the
development
buddy you are masterful with some of
these words the way you say this [ __ ]
stop it's great dude i love it thank you
buddy
[ __ ] um all right oh we're having fun
jesus christ let it the dead air that's
my bed no it's
i love your market it's market buddy
come on why are you gonna tip them off
they're giving me more work never would
have thought it would tell me to edit
this [ __ ]
let's just stay in it yeah what do you
mean we don't edit it it's a real deal
right here
it's the real feel all right i just
don't want to [ __ ] up the computer this
is the only one i got
thanks to my wife not with your credit
yeah yeah this is
you have to wait eight months to get one
i know um all right this is from sean
new patron first question
ever grab a refill on your popcorn on
your way out of the movies
i didn't think of it but it sounds
fantastic and are you allowed to do that
this is the guy that won't take home
leftovers i still think about that and
it still pisses me i know
that and what there was something else i
told you about it probably multiple
times
that you have there's something else i
posted i forget what the [ __ ] it was
on instagram and you texted me like dude
i'm really upset
[ __ ] i forget what it was it wasn't it
wasn't left over she also grew up rich
no it was asking for no ice
you asked for no ice i love asking what
the [ __ ] what kind of water did i take
when i came in here can i
hold one what did i prefer you preferred
room temperature that's an indian thing
guys
yeah it's yeah it's a very american
thing for the
the cold water what's up yeah what's
what's the reasoning behind this
i think hot water is actually supposed
to be the best for you and i remember
i've heard that as well work with an
asian guy at a restaurant that always
drank hot water in the yeah
and he always swore that it hydrates
your body quicker because when you drink
the cold water
it kind of like shuts down your system
for a second and shocks your system i
believe that i also think i just drink
more if i i can just
like this is probably the second bottle
i've had today crushing it if you're
trying to drink a lot of water
it's just much easier to drink if it's
not cold how close you get the brain
freeze he's going all slow i love it
when it's cold though
everything about you you don't love
water ice air conditioning i do look
listen i do love water so long as it is
what'd you say so long as there's cool
air as long as it has a sugary treat in
there
water with a little high fructose corn
syrup sprinkled in there
no i do love water i do but it's got to
be ice cold do you say water
water water yeah yeah i'll say wood or
water yeah my girls were philly so i'm
familiar yeah she's from not
too far we like yeah i look like some
northeast boys
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's uh she
you're the right girl i grew up like ten
minutes away from her she yeah she moved
to
she grew up in northeast then bucks
county yes for most of her time same
same same exact story anybody in the
northeast that makes a couple of bucks
you move like five minutes outside
philly that's what we did
you moved to like ben salem and [ __ ]
you're like oh she was in benson yeah
you have a i live like two towns over
you get like
my my dad had a good run in like from
like 88 to [ __ ] 90 and they're like
that's it we're out of here and then at
all the real dad or the one you love the
real dad
okay yeah i'm not sure if there's one i
love but the real dad
i'm kidding i love everybody continuing
to pull on the heartstrings
jesus christ but i don't make this kid
cry by the end of this thing no i'm dead
inside you're talking about the dad to
live you're the one that abandoned you
foley's loving this because the whole
first 10 minutes of the pod he was
just sitting there like how do i turn
him out on tipping because that's the
way he operates i felt bad because i
don't want to make fun of totally fully
too much for being fat
because when we first that's our bread
and butter off pod we first sat down he
was like am i in the frame and i was
like what kind of [ __ ] question is
that like you don't know the answer
and then it just you're in next door too
ah all right let's see here uh people
look through the [ __ ] empire state do
you find it like you see
he's just [ __ ] hang on a second dad
what's going on
all right that didn't work with the
headphones that will cut out
that was also just mean a little bit i
can't make fun of your dad because he
watches
by the way love you buddy that [ __ ]
mama stuck
we're back let's go you had me on the
[ __ ] ropes
let's go start slamming my head at the
table
you spill again what's going on i just i
didn't get to it before
um all right let's move on let's see
here
um this cooking and we also said we're
we're starting to get a level of family
a level of trash that we
you know weren't really prepped for when
the show starts of course
this one is does anybody this is from
josh does anyone in your family have a
tongue ring
his 52 year old uncle has oh my god
which is he shouldn't be allowed at the
family parties actually that's weird
what do you think he voted for
i don't think he's allowed to vote and
does he play with it because that was
always the worst thing people would play
with and be like sticking out of their
mouth like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah for sure he hangs out at the
hooters yeah yeah he's a me tour for
sure
no yeah that's and we have no p we're
not uh we've always been pretty good
with that the foley's piercings tattoos
et cetera et cetera
always down the line not not too shabby
i can't foresee you
now right yeah you ever pierced no you
didn't i'm surprised i could see you in
high school
i felt so like try hard and that was one
thing i never wanted to be was try hard
and i'm not saying i'm the most secure
guy at all
but like i never wanted to and i never
wanted to be obvious i'm trying harder
yeah it's probably what it is well when
you're yeah you're two
two years older than me i think and when
i guess we were in high school and
in college those diamond studs were oh
yeah
yeah they were like the [ __ ]
everybody had those
yeah they were all fake though i mean
most of them yeah
yeah who cares it was like when fabulous
had the ones that were like this [ __ ]
big yeah did you have your ears pierced
no i don't think i was really allowed
yeah i can't see you doing it either
tattoo no no no no no
we're a bunch of vanilla [ __ ] i i had
one ear pierced yeah and i was walking
through a mall and i saw this
just such a gross fat kid walking with
one ear pierced
and i was like is that what i [ __ ]
look like and then instead of taking it
out i went to claire's got the other one
pierced like an even
bigger bozo
you guys had the gay ear right you
pierced the gay or in the straight ear
what my dick
no no you're used to say if your left
ear was pierced your strength that was a
big 90s thing yeah that was like the 80s
and 90s
if your right ear was pierced you were
gay yeah oh yeah like
it was like an old-school like 70s like
under the table signaling thing
i think yeah yeah yeah i didn't even
know that was real i just thought it was
one of those things that we used to
believe in the 90s
i think there was a lot of [ __ ] in the
90s that you were like yeah did you hear
oh yeah yeah
yeah gary pennecoley with the gerbil
that was i mean every local news guy
yeah yeah
um all right this one's from preston uh
never had a question read does your
family only air condition certain parts
of the house
which as my parents get older they live
in a pretty big house it's like
it's a smart move there's rooms that
they like cover the vents and stuff like
that
yeah they're getting a little dicey with
it and they keep it hot as [ __ ] and cold
hottest [ __ ] in the summer and coldest
[ __ ] in the winter they sit there and
[ __ ] ski jackets watching tv we have
like they're on the [ __ ] ski lift we
have different temperature settings in
our
three rooms and the one that nobody
stays in i'm like why the [ __ ] would
this ever be on
yeah close the door close the door turn
it off yeah keep the [ __ ] cold
everywhere else but
why are we wasting money here whole
house keep it cranking
how many ac units you got right right
now one and it does it does the job
how many btus is it i don't know i
couldn't tell you no
1200 000. after that btu
yeah i think it's gotta be the low ones
are like five that's like 150 dollars
but yeah you gotta you gotta go like
over nine to fifteen when i was a kid my
parents were the king of that though we
had one
you could do cgi for the coke polar bear
for sure
he's just got a bunch of those green
we would all sleep in the living room on
real hot days
which i only remember the air
conditioner coming out or getting put on
at a certain time in the summer
and it wasn't [ __ ] may or june it was
easily july
yeah and then they would put uh blankets
up over the
the like the entrance ways out of the
living and we'd all sleep in there what
are they building a fort
they're [ __ ] adults that's crazy
yeah we had central air when we moved to
the uh
our new house we got central air you are
pure garbage dog 100
we got central and that we have central
air central air
now yeah get it from our neighbors
just tap into their line now we have
central air now but when i was a kid now
now pure garbage how old are you 45.
just getting late for you together we
hit a buzzer beater though that's what
bobby kelly said
he goes right at the [ __ ] nick of
time you guys are getting yeah we're
cooking i just told you my air
conditioner is running all the time
no i'm saying i'm living out there i'm
just saying you know what i mean health
let's
let's focus on that 40 i'm focused yeah
okay
see that's because it's hot in here i'm
sweating everybody else is sweating too
i'm actually quite comfortable drinking
my warm water i got a can of soup or
something over here
uh all right let's see uh this is from
sideshow bub do you or did you curse in
front of your grandparents or parents
i used to think it was really funny to
curse in front of my grandparents
because i didn't think they knew what it
meant
in english yeah yeah and i think they
did now
looking back yeah yeah yeah but they
wouldn't say anything yeah i thought it
was so funny
11 year old you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then i don't cause
in front of my parents
out of respect but they know i cuss all
the time i just don't do it at them i'm
real i don't cuz around kids like i'm
very
those are important things to me i i was
home
at my mom's house not too long ago when
she was it was like two weeks ago she
and i was fighting over
i was fighting with somebody on the
phone and
i think it was like the ads or something
and we were getting screwed is what was
happening i was yeah
i was losing it right and i'm on the
phone it wasn't the edge or something
else and i'm on the phone
and uh i'm like what the [ __ ] is the
[ __ ] problem
and my mom's sitting there with my like
two-year-old niece she's like we're
gonna go play downstairs
yeah you know the northeast they don't
do that as much and i think it's more
i think most of like the politeness of
the south and the rudeness of the
northeast is just population density
yeah there's too many people to be
polite in new york i don't have [ __ ]
time
in the south if i'm walking by a person
and say hi howdy that's the only person
i'ma see for a hundred feet
yeah yeah hey how are you i'm doing well
you'd be a crazy person who said hi to
everybody in new york how are you doing
how are you
literally crazy so i think even cussing
around kids like in the south i don't
see it i don't see that many kids on a
day to day so it's easier so it's easy
to edit hey
we're at chick-fil-a or whatever the
[ __ ] there's some kids there just watch
it in the northeast
it's just constant people all the time
sure if i'm on the train in new york
there's always kids there's kids 24
hours a day i can't i can't wash my
mouth
yeah but you curse a lot on stage your
parents come to your shows we're not
allowed to watch my shows
really really i mean they might still
watch but like i've let them come to one
show and i made sure i didn't cuss at
that show
really yeah i can't handle it that's
crazy
and bombing in front of your parents
dogs
dude i've done it a couple of times not
too long ago
it's rough because they don't get that
it's it's gonna happen oh you're
no matter how long how good you are
occupational hazard it's you you're
going to bomb yeah it is a [ __ ]
certainty
occasional bombs and even if a person
knows that going in if that's the show
they watch you where you bomb they're
like this guy's what's up
yeah even if they know he's probably his
next one will be fine they're like nah
but
he said they watched you bomb yeah
you've eaten it in front of your mom a
few
more so than any comic i've ever met
because usually it was if we were doing
shows in philly before people started
coming to the shows
but you know three four years ago a lot
of it was populated with kevin's family
they would all come out because
we would go back and do a one like me
you
cotton and like whoever would do like
one show a year in philly and we get
like all friends and family to come out
and stuff like that
and those shows we all did well on but
there were some other ones
that like we were working like like this
[ __ ] side room and a thing
and then like my mom would put it on
facebook her
cousins would come oh my god dude i've
been getting heckled by like my third
by my mom's third cousin and [ __ ] my
aunt and uncle came to [ __ ] kiss kiss
bang bang or whatever it was that place
in ac
oh my god oh i remember that
you ate it too didn't you there's no way
to not you're next to stripper poles
yeah
you're on like a nine foot stage yeah i
think i had a sport coat on too i think
i was wearing a sport coat that night
i remember that sweat yeah bombing up
there with the cordless mic
oh 50 foot ceilings i remember there was
this ridiculously attractive waitress at
that show
and not that i would ever not be
faithful to my girl but like
the like there was no if i was trying to
cheat i'd be like there's no way she
respects
me doing this show oh no yeah yeah comic
that you see
on this stage no next to two go-go
dancer poles yes
where the stage is also the stage is
just an extension of the bar as well
yeah
so they're like they're working behind
you at the moment like get the [ __ ] out
of here it was actually nice to not even
have that in my brain of a possibility
it's out it's gone yeah dude we did we
did one in ac we did
like four in a week in any scene each
one was worse than the [ __ ] next
and um there's like 13 people or
something oh
[ __ ] nightmare dude we're just taking
it on the [ __ ] chin
and he was he was nice enough he was
like dude i'll cause when we go headline
we would flip-flop
yeah and he's like he was nice enough to
be like i'll close these shows out
because you've been getting the raw end
of the deal yeah and i remember i'm
bombing this guy comes in remember the
guy
came in just walked in the club sat in
the front row pulls his phone
it's just like mayhem and i'm ready to
i'm at my wit's end and i'm like then i
see
i didn't realize my uncle was in the
crowd oh my god we're like at like
minutes
we had to do 35 minutes a minute 33 i
see my uncle just like
rubbing his forehead and i'm like oh
i'm like guys i lost my tire i think i
cried in the broom closet after the show
he gave kevin 20
and said don't come to thanksgiving call
your dad
i did that show while i was going broke
and nothing fit my mood better than that
show
like that was i was like this is where i
belong right now
i'm so happy we don't have to do those
anymore for the time being i love it
emilio keeps trying to get me back and
i'm just like no that show gave me covid
i did i went back to ac at a different
venue with him and i got covered
and then gave it to everybody that we
canceled because of you got covered we
were supposed to be the weekend after
you you're welcome we canceled but we're
doing it
next weekend june 18th june 18th baby
fantastic socially distant i think can't
wait it's going to be hot
um jesus christ that's so funny i forgot
about that yeah look you
got home and you're like akash has it he
got in atlantic city and you called
we're like this is getting too hairy
yeah we're not doing it it's getting
dicey out you're out um all right let's
do a couple of more here this one's from
ryan coates this just says have you ever
played doctor
no no i should have maybe i'd be a gift
when you were a kid
no what talking about when you were a
kid i think
like sexually he's saying yeah yeah
absolutely
kidding me he had a [ __ ] regular
office hours
[Laughter]
uh i got yeah i got to talk to my
assistant shall we
i got call playing with a girl a couple
weeks ago
[Laughter]
it was one of those things where like i
didn't know what was that i was young we
were both young and everybody was like
ah look at this
and it was just like getting made fun of
i'm like i don't know what you're making
fun of me for
but i don't like it i know you're i
don't think i don't think you're a
licensed physician
or at any place to make that call yeah
absolutely man [ __ ] doctor all that
stuff truth or dare
[ __ ] seven minutes in heaven or
whatever it's called never do any of
that [ __ ]
really yeah yeah you grew up in a real
like 80s movie yeah he is john q america
dude he really is
yeah you live that life should i see
pedophiles and pizza parties
spin the bottle you played that hell
yeah that was like something we would
only see on tv
like it would be like if somebody would
ever like let's play spin the bottom of
the truth they would be like get the
[ __ ] out that was the very 80s versus
90s
you grew up in like a white trash
version of full house sure
you could say that yeah yeah yeah a
couple of uncles
i know yeah dude [ __ ] spin the bottle
like any time there was like a party
in like you know seventh eighth grade
seventh eighth grade ninth grade party
and then after that it was just they
were [ __ ] like ragers they were
parties yeah parents weren't home
but yeah parents went to sleep or
whatever we would sneak out we would all
like seven of us would stay at my one
buddies and we'd sneak out to the girls
house where her parents were away and
like seven girls were staying
spin the bottle truth or dare that's
literally out of like an 80s
that kid got [ __ ] that kid right there
kid did all right
he was a good kid how's this guy doing
not so good
that kid's real disappointed oh man
he would be right oh man
that if he knew what i grew up to be
yeah he'd be giving you a wedgie
oh dawg he'd be stuffing me in a locker
you can't fit in the locker come on
i think he meant storage
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
have you ever had a storage unit you've
had a storage yeah i have yeah well we
were in miami so we had all these things
yeah that doesn't happen in new york or
in hoba
or wherever yeah in c caucus caucus let
me ask you this
did you get movers to move in yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but they don't unpack and that's
where you're really [ __ ] in the ass
because we moved on such short notice we
didn't have the time to do the like we
don't need this let's throw it out
you brought everything for everything
and so we're as we're moving in we're
throwing out tons of [ __ ] it was a hold
nightmare
furniture that we're like that belonged
in jersey it does not belong here
yeah all of our friends you got an
elevator are you an elevator building or
walking out yeah elevator
nice
thirty-one you're on the way first floor
holy
menswear holy [ __ ] i love it spending a
little bit of that cash
i don't even know those buildings went
up that high over there toby get him a
fresh hot water will you
classy damn all right
30k 31st nice view
uh decent view yeah yeah i like the view
well where do you look south
north south and then a little bit west
oh is there a helicopter river is there
a
helicopter
you can see the river yeah i can see the
river is there a helicopter pad on the
top of your building
not at all but i will say one thing that
i really liked is i could see the empire
state building
and that was like i [ __ ] came here
and i was broke here and now i
i'm looking i i beat this [ __ ] oh look
at that it just [ __ ] hurt me
i beat this [ __ ] like i let jit got
emotional when i saw it
because i kept saying wherever i live i
want that and my girl didn't fight me on
it but i think it was like kind of odd
to her
just like this is why you like you care
so much about this and then when i got
up there and i looked out the window i
was like
i [ __ ] slept on a mattress on the
floor with
mice running by my face all night i did
that whole [ __ ] that everybody did and
now i'm looking at you like a [ __ ]
guy
uh i got that that's funny they say
they're fantastic that's the building
the most that people
acquire like a personal weird
relationship with where they speak to it
in a first person i don't speak to it
necessarily in the first person but like
well you said there you are yeah i guess
i was thinking like i beat new york like
not the builder yeah i'm like new york i
[ __ ] got you like
i came i did it i made it here yeah damn
yeah and ripped off amex in the process
and a couple of hospitals take that 4k
and shove it up your ass [ __ ]
yeah you can have the cash back i don't
give a [ __ ] um all right let's do two or
three more this one
is from brad ever try to make a bloomin
onion at home
which is a [ __ ] garbage movie it also
sounds so fire though
if you figure if you crack the code it
can make him at home yeah you're it's
probably pretty good king
yeah i've told you this before you're
not going to believe me
never had one i've only had a couple of
times
where is that it's that output it's
onion rings
yeah yeah and you like pull it right
yeah yeah yeah great it's a fun time
we should do that on the road i've
always wanted oh yeah patreon content
buddy
there you go foley has another heart
attack
that's so funny because i want to do all
these like food things but i'm like i'm
trying to get him to lose weight at the
same time
yeah so it's like a dance of like hey
you can go to a chief day
like a cheat half day maybe uh 45 years
of it yeah
yeah i know but i'm saying you're
straight for six and a half days
and then one meal you go [ __ ] hammer
okay and then that's
six and a half days of clean eating all
right
not just clean living clean eating
that's like giving an alcoholic a shot
of jameson yeah
you gotta go cold turkey yeah but he's
not gonna go cold turkey is a thing
so i'm thinking yeah he does like hot
turkey
doesn't an open-faced turkey sandwich
shout out
shout out to them the open face turkey
sandwich but there's got to be a way we
got to get this [ __ ]
we're working on we're doing a weight
loss challenge on the patreon it's not
going so well
haven't gained one pound in seven months
yeah but that's not enough you gained
six a week ago
from wayne away in last week you were
six pounds heavier but still as i said
he's the same right now currently months
ago which is
kind of a win but that's not enough
buddy kind of a win
i'll tell you what i'll take it yeah no
i think the problem is we're viewing
that as a win
yeah that should be not alone i'm gonna
celebrate you for that but i'm also
gonna say you gotta [ __ ] lose weight
bro millions of dollars on the line
thank you
i love that can i have that now can i
get that up front
no because you'll blow it all on [ __ ]
coke and fat
coke that's the name of the title
[Laughter]
but i'm telling you dog you guys are the
the hot ones andrew said it well you
guys are hot ones for trey i think how
much [ __ ] money that guy's making
he doesn't know what to do with it
youtube ad revenues out the [ __ ]
through the moon any podcast ready to do
you're gonna get paid on you got your
patreon is cracking
it's millions of dollars i'm not saying
that exaggerated i think you'll have
that potential
but it all rests on your [ __ ] weight
on your
fat ass back i'm on it i'm on eyes a
professional dog his credit gonna get
cleaned up
toby on it you hilarious but you got to
get your weight in order and i'm saying
that because i love you i'm telling you
i love you too if i didn't give a [ __ ]
about you
i would be like yeah you know whatever
but i'm telling you you guys got too
much potential to [ __ ] not
lose weight it's not going to it's not
going to promise you to think about
how do you think i feel this is so rare
i lay in bed at night going cool i got a
career ah [ __ ] it's all based on
foley
it's all based on keeping his fat pizza
[ __ ] alive you're so [ __ ] funny
it's kind of funny and it's so rare to
have two funny people with chemistry
and y'all got decades of friendship oh
you gotta [ __ ] you gotta do it i got
it i got it
i got it i said this to you off pod so
it was more like hearthstone
yeah i remember but my exact words were
it's about everything you ever wanted is
about to come true
i know but you have to be able to enjoy
it i know otherwise
the everlasting gobstopper
and we love it and we love you guys
can i pee before we do the real podcast
are we done with patreon
no this is the pod oh this isn't on page
patreon oh no this isn't patreon oh we
do patreon questions
on the real show can i do a bathroom
break either way yeah we're wrapping up
we'll wrap it up right now let's do one
more uh this is from uncle cracker ever
wash his suit in the washing machine
which i mean what are we doing that's i
love that yo
i thought about it that's garbage
through and through you just can't dry
it
yeah i assume if you watch it on like a
low tumbler i've done it i've done that
a gentle yeah you shouldn't be doing
that get it [ __ ] dry cleaned
it's nine bucks i tell you what those
steamers man
you don't have to wash clothes anymore
hit it with the [ __ ] steamer you're
in and out of the door
steamer little febreze [ __ ] keep it
moving
no no let's try it all right let's wrap
it up gang thank you so much for tuning
in with us akash you got anything coming
up you want the folks to know about him
yeah i'm doing shows uh kansas city
please buy tickets to that if you're
listening please for [ __ ] sake buy
tickets to that
uh i'm in san diego july second and
third you know what can i just read this
yeah yeah please please do all right i'm
gonna announce a couple shows
let's do it
this weekend i'm at i don't know if this
is going to be out but i'm at bananas in
hasbrook heights new jersey you don't
need to come to that
uh 17th june 17th through 19th kansas
city comedy club of kc
july 1st through 3rd san diego at
american comedy club july 22nd through
24th i'm at magooby's joke house in
baltimore
september 23rd to 25th i'm in austin
with you guys
yeah moon tower shout out to moon tower
sneak onto your pod whether you like it
or not
dc i haven't announced this yet october
8th and 9th i'm at the comedy loft
toronto i got a lot of fans in toronto
because a lot of indians
uh october 15th at the gran gerard
theater and then
theater oh yeah buddy that's my first
theater so we got to sell oh i love it
and then
uh november 11th through 13th i met
helium in indianapolis so hopefully
yeah look at it guys go see him live
he's a [ __ ] monster killer
insane yeah insane how funny he is um
guys make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes
youtube that whole thing live show and
patreon.com the tickets to the live show
will be
in the description of the episode go get
some tickets oh real quick start
interrupt my ticket my website is
akashing.com and also flagrant two
podcast checks oh yeah yeah
of course um gang we love you very much
akash we love you toby we love you
kippy i love you buddy i love you too
dad and we love you guys thank you buddy
it was awesome